[Music]
so day one of the middle split challenge
so yeah i used to be able to do the
middle split actually
like two years ago so kind of before
corona because i danced a lot so i
practiced a lot of stretching and
everything but the last
two years i guess i haven't really done
any stretching at all except for one
week
one day a week a little bit of yoga
and that's it and that's not enough to
keep up your flexibility so i'm gonna
try this week to see if i can reach the
middle split again by just doing a few
youtube tutorials and also going a
little bit more regularly to yoga and
dance classes
and then we'll see where i'm at at the
end of the week compared to the
beginning of the week
so yeah flexibility challenge day one
[Music]
okay
so this is day two of the middle split
challenge
and
um
yesterday went really bad actually i i
couldn't even reach the floor at all and
i can do the pancake on good days and i
used to be able to do the middle splits
but right now
during corona
i kinda
[ __ ] up everything
so i'm not able to do it anymore but
yeah we're first gonna do a little bit
of a warming up and then
i'm gonna do some simple stretches
ending with the middle split stretches
which are a lot more intense
so
warming up is important
that's that's my only advice yeah so
we're gonna try and see how that goes
and i'll link some videos that i usually
use when training for the middle split
um that i find really helpful
so you can try it as well at home if you
want to
[Music]
[Music]
so on average this week i stretched in
the morning for around 30 minutes and in
the evening around 30 minutes
and i wouldn't recommend stretching much
more as you could hurt yourself
otherwise and that's not what we want
then i usually use some yoga blocks to
support myself for deeper stretches a
foam roller for that really deep muscle
work
and a timer i set to 30 minutes
of course you also need your yoga mat
and some
loose clothing
and that's kind of it then it's just
basically consistency
and eventually you will get your splits
if you just do this for
in my case a week but perhaps for you it
will take a little bit longer
yeah enjoy the journey that's basically
my only advice
[Music]
so for the last two days i already felt
i was pretty close
and i think then most people have the
tendency to really push themselves into
it but don't do that i one time really
hurt myself and couldn't do the splits
for almost a year
so just relax and breathe and your body
will naturally go into the position
again
and also always keep your core tight
this just helps with general body
awareness and will disable you to really
hurt yourself
i also have some dips that i apply daily
to increase my flexibility and i think
following these will really help you
with overall body mobility
not just towards the splits but in
general
so i think one of the biggest things
with overall mobility is that most of us
just sit too much so i think
less sitting is one of the best things
you can do so for example just prop your
laptop up on a higher surface and use it
as a standing desk or every 60 minutes
for example stand up for five minutes
and just stretch a little bit this will
already help so much
so another big tip that i heard is this
so-called ground living so the idea is
that you just sit on the ground and you
kind of try to put yourself in natural
positions so this can be a lotus
position or just bending forward a
little bit and the idea is then that you
don't use furniture which in general is
just kind of bad for your back
and of course i do still use my desk
chair but one of the big things we have
to think about is posture just sit up
straight it's so important
so then another big one i heard is to
not use pillows and it depends a little
bit if you sleep on your side or back if
you sleep on your back though don't use
them it's just a bit better for the
general alignment of your body
so another big one is to try to stretch
during the day so whilst you do chores
for example like washing the dishes or
when you're brushing your
teeth to just bend forward
and try to touch the floor these kind of
little moments will add up in total
towards your overall flexibility
[Music]
and just try to move during the day so
take walks take the stairs etc and i
hope these kind of tips will help you
during the day and in general to
become more flexible
and hopefully reach the goals that you
want
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this is the last day of the
challenge so i kind of wanted to give a
little bit of the tips and tricks of
what i learned whilst doing this
challenge so here you can see how far i
actually got so i could finally reach
the floor again
after
one and a half years two years
and as i said before i could do the
pancake but now i could get my feet to
also stretch outward fully so one of the
things that i learned whilst doing this
challenge
and researching extremely flexible
people on youtube is that most of them
actually have a lifestyle that allows
them to be really flexible so for
example they're dancers or athletes
and then people like us look at them and
think like oh my god how can i become
like that
whilst we're just sitting at an office
job for eight hours a day so i think
whilst doing this challenge i kind of
realized
instead of these super intense
stretching routines that most people
follow it's actually
more important to kind of take a
holistic approach
where you also redesign your environment
to allow you to be more flexible so for
example
while sitting on the floor to stretch
forward or whilst watching tv to kind of
try to touch your toes
because these kind of little things that
you do during the day add up so much
more than if you just at the end of the
day do a super intense stretching
routine so one of the things i would
also recommend
is to work on your strength alongside
your flexibility because about five
years ago i injured myself really badly
by trying to go in the
sideward split
whilst i actually wasn't strong enough
so i really stretched every every day
and pushed myself really hard but i
actually didn't work on my strengths and
that kind of made me tear my limp which
um or tear my hamstring
which
is a super hard injury to recover from
it took me almost a year
and it was my right leg and my right leg
now is still my bad leg like stretching
wise and i really hope to kind of
continue this
stretching journey that i have been
doing for the last five days or this
routine because what i actually really
want to achieve is the needle as you can
see here and i'm still pretty far off
because my backbends aren't
super good and i also don't have enough
strength to kind of throw my leg up that
high
but i think i'll be working on it
through the weeks and perhaps around
december or something i will do another
little
week video um to show my progress
so i hope you guys also learned
something and perhaps also work on your
flexibility yourself because i would
love to hear how you guys work on your
flexibility increase it and how the
journey is for you in general so see you
soon
[Music]
you